[Music]
I am really really grateful for this
invitation and you may be surprised by
this but I even like the weather hell is
for me some stupid Mediterranean
Mediterranean Beach with with all the
Sun and so on oh this is the weather
that I like okay so I am a little bit
afraid that in which direction to take
because most of you are not philosophers
so I will try in this maximum quarter of
an hour introduction to maybe I will do
it like this to begin with - to begin
with more not purely philosophical stuff
but some stuff with philosophical
consequences and then conclude with some
political remarks let me it will be a
little bit I will be associating and so
on I don't want to bore you I would like
to begin with two Jewish jokes which has
a deep properly metaphysical meaning one
I've already used in my old books
hopefully you all don't know it the
other one is fresh only now I learned
about it the first one is that classical
one you knows on Shabbat on Saturday
Jewish believers meet in a synagogue and
each of them says something so first a
big rabbi said oh my god I know buddy I
am NOT not worthy of your attention God
then rich Jewish merchant comes and says
oh my god I'm also nobody don't even
consider me I'm not worthy of your
attention then I hope you know the joke
a poor Jew stands up and says God I'm
also a nobody and then the rich merchant
kicks the rabbi and said who is this guy
that you think he can also say that he
there is deep truth in this whenever
somebody's apparently humiliates himself
and so on adopts this attitude of I
despise my name my identity blah blah be
very careful for looking for secret
privilege
what is the Lacanian I would have called
surplus enjoyment that I will give an
example which may be even provocative to
some of you and written about it
extensively in United States in this
politically correct Isles
there is one basic rule very simple
further that you are from a white male
Protestant whatever elite more you are
allowed to assert your particular ethnic
religious identity like Native American
so-called they hate this term Indians I
prefer to call them you know my clock
which really happened in Missoula
Montana
one Indian refer to it to himself as
Indian and immediately a white
well-meaning liberal interrupted him no
your Native American don't you know them
you are humiliating yourself
and the Indian gave a perfect answer he
says no sorry Native Americans for me
much more racist it means I am Native
American part of nature and what are you
cultural Americana was he said I prefer
to be called Indian in this way at least
my name is a sign of white men's UPD do
you know they thought there in India he
got it correctly
no sorry let's go
so Native Americans okay black okay then
Chinese suspicion begins Italians may be
German Scandinavia's but if white was
anglo-saxon or whatever if you just say
I also want to assert my identity you
are a fascist you're decried as the
fascist and so on now I know well found
that reasoning behind this because this
is effectively the hegemonic position
it's not the same for you or for a poor
Native American to say I want to assert
my identities but at ulta something else
how beneath and now talking about these
typical multicultural leftist liberals
beneath this self humiliating lecture oh
we are guilty for everything imperialist
colonizers will we don't have the right
renouncing all your particular figures
always comes with in a discreet way
asserting your position of universality
all these apparently modest self
denigrating white people at the same
time I noticed have no problems behaving
in a very patronizing way towards others
correcting them telling them when they
when they are making a mistake or
whatever whatever
so clearly the secret profit is this
moral authority given to you in this way
I think there is something of the same
with how in Europe and I have all
sympathy for them but nonetheless how in
Europe leftists left liberals behaved
towards immigrants of course we should
be my god
my position is do not be afraid very
less this year I just know this crowd in
their very
understanding of immigrants how they
always already patronize them like if
immigrants do and like all people they
are a mixed crowd there are criminals
among them and so if they do something
horrible rape and so on white liberals
are always looking for an excuse oh this
is just general human nature we are all
like that or they were so victimized by
us we should understand this and so on
and so on
and one of my immigrant friends exploded
and told me that he's it's a beautiful
peridot philosophical he told me my god
my basic human right is at least to be
recognized as an adult responsible
person which practically means to be
able to do something horrible are they
aware that by treating me almost like a
child in this way they are humiliating
me and so on and so on so I think that
again ok I will not go into political
consequences here just be aware how also
with political correctness all often the
position of a victim can be used as a
nice instrument to justify your exerting
of in academia American it's typical in
outside victims are really victims but
in academia playing with victimhood if
you're a privileged victim gives you an
incredible power de-facto that would be
my first point let's go to the second
point so I mentioned the lotion this
surplus enjoyment profit that you get
from
apparently denigrating humiliating
yourself and this is my regalian
Lacanian standpoint that every position
of subject every subject even the most
empty cartesian subject has to rely on
this
type of small filter surplus enjoyment
which sustains his/her/its subjectivity
I will give you another example here
short philosophical idea I although I
was accused of I don't know what I
really for theoretical reasons read the
last chapter in my last book where I
explained it but I really believe in
subversive potential not in descriptions
they cause disorder but some deep
insights on which LGBTQ this trans
grander ism is based but since we are
here also among some of your list
philosophers I would like to draw an
attention to it
you know that the official term is now
LGBT plus or LGBTQ whatever plus now
usual sorry to be critical against at
least part of your tradition but usually
this plus is understood in
empiricist way a British empiricism is
this one it's not just the binary
sexuality male or female blah blah there
are dozens multiplicity of gender or sex
positions and since no classification
can be really exhausting what is another
guy comes and says I read your
classification but I'm not neither by
gender nor boobs nor death nor a sexual
and something else so it's the simple
worry what if we nonetheless miss some
position so let's leave the space open I
think and it's not me it's a I forgot
her name but it's a very good lgbtq+
theoretician lady from Australia who did
a proper Galleon move and said no what
if we when you have LGBT you plus what
if we define this plus itself as a
specific position I can be a plus and
this is I think even the best
definition of a subject a subject is not
simply something a subject is always in
excess of what he/she it is and this is
why and very fast here if you want to
know more read my books or whatever this
is why not only psychoanalysis is not
male chauvinist
but it's eminently feminist in the sense
that subject as such is ultimately
feminine why because this defines for me
ultimately femininity this self
questioning attitude which can be
discerned even in some most superficial
annoying features you know like you are
in love with the woman and she will
sooner or later ask you tell me why do
you love me but it's a very deep
question you know why because of course
it has no answer I mean the moment you
know it the moment you can say because
of your eyes because of your legs
because of your laughter it's not love
laugh must be that plus X in other words
hysterical questioning is the most
elementary forum for me of critique of
ideology ideology is in very very
central
ideology is an order aleady ology if it
is most elementary what society tells
you that you are you are a man a Muslim
a Christian atheist Democrat worker
whatever works but the most elementary
questioning is this why am i what you
are saying that I earn this not
accepting any objective position as
yours and here again the function of the
plus is crucial
that's why intelligent psychoanalysis
always prefers hysteria to perversion
perversion is a claim even in clinical
terms
always conformist perversely simply the
hidden aspect of a power structure but
ok let's not lose time my second my
second joke and then some political
remarks which goes more into because I
am an atheist but the Christian idea is
there is not green to this what this
means what does this mean for theology a
Jewish friend told me and for at least
for me this joke is new I didn't hear it
before a wonderful story it's I warn you
it's no trigger warning is needed
nothing dirty happens but it's a very
cruel joke and I discovered with wonder
and respect how do you know that there
is a whole tradition of Jewish jokes
about Auschwitz not triply making fun
but drawing out the paradoxes and there
is something we don't have time to go
into it now very deep in it I claim that
when for tragedy to take place it must
happen what is going on within certain
limits where the victim retains its
dignity you know tragic victim when
things get really terrifying amount of
comedy has to enter which is not a
comedy where you just laugh but
horrifying comedies ok so the joke is
this one in paradise some Jews who were
slaughtered at Auschwitz nice life there
sit at the bend and talk about their
memories of how they were killed making
fun of it like one says to another do
remember Drake of how when they direct
you to gas chamber you slipped on
something and hit your head and died
even before you entered gas chamber in
the area that was so funny and so on
now comes the deep inside then God also
taking a break God Himself walks by them
listens at these drugs and says sorry
guys I don't understand it
now I'm sorry too for you to understand
the point of this joke you must know
that this whole theological tradition of
claiming God died at Auschwitz things
that happened there are so horrible that
they cannot be in any way combined with
the idea of divinity as the hidden
master of the universe lake goddess God
as they put it
that's crucial as many theologies put it
God was not there ok so God comes there
and says sorry guys I don't understand
it then one of the truth goes to God
embrace the scheme in the petraju gran
says don't worry our lord you were not
there so of course you cannot understand
it you know but you know what's the
beauty it's not in this version it's not
that God cannot understand the horror he
can is all-powerful she cannot
understand how it's possible to make a
joke out of it God doesn't get the joke
in this sense I will not go into it now
I think that what I call materialist
theology has retains God not as real God
old guy up there but as some kind of an
presupposed agency which registers
things you know and we all rely on it as
Jacques Lacan put it the moment we talk
we believe in God why because we believe
that when something is spoken out
registered it exists in a different way
to give an extremely simple example
didn't it happen to you unfortunately
with my bad manners if Toffler happens
to me you are with a couple of friends
and some of you in that case it was me
did something horrible and faithful you
know that everybody else knows it and
everybody knows that all other knows it
but nonetheless everything claimed rest
the moment one says this publicly
at the moment of registration but what I
want to say is that I like this
theological idea that God is like a
benevolent master who allows you small
leafless where like where you can
violate even his prohibitions you know
they got like a proper severe
old-fashioned father today in our post
patriarchal era I almost like them
because no matter how severe dates
pretend to be
that's how traditional Authority
functions the idea is always do it
violate my prohibitions but discreetly I
don't want to know about it and
according to some good geologists this
is even what you have in 10 commandments
you know the commandment don't celebrate
other gods this is not the correct
transition it's in the Bible Old
Testament a much more ambiguous
statement which basically means don't
don't press other gods in my presence
like you know do it but discreetly and
okay I will not get lost here I'm
talking too much so we can go on in the
debate if you want about modes of
authority today I would just like
conclude with a very simple joke abused
in some of my texts but they were not
published in big media you probably
don't know it where are we today I am
still some kind of critique of ideology
and what is happening I claim is that
ideology is now alive but in new modes
there are two I think main modes one a
week two you probably know the old
formula of Marx religion is the opium of
the people I think now we have to change
this formula that we have now I hope you
will get the joke I often use it in
talks but not here we
have today two new Opium's of the people
you can guess which ones literally opium
and the people one is opium literally if
you read statistics at least in the
generate spaces like academia and so on
you know that literally in United States
rate around 80 percent of professors
students already into pro-second all
that stuff like we literally need a
support in chemistry and so on just two
functions relatively normally and at all
levels from this simple anti-depressive
to drugs proper whatever what's so
interesting is the circular nature of
this support first if you are too
excited you take a Kuhlman to calm you
down but then you miss desire you take
another drug to recess it so this is a
very important thing how for our daily
cycle our life to function we have more
and more to rely on different drugs in
this metaphoric sense opium ii people i
think that precisely the big opium today
is people populism and for reasons that
we can debate later i don't want to go
into it now that's why i have doubts
about bodies getting popular now among
some european leftist leftist populism
in the sense of oh if the right can do
it successfully rightist populism it's
kind of I call it ironically perverted
me too why not me too
why we'll know I think that populism is
always this gesture of simplification
you create an image of the enemy and it
may work in short term but not really
for example in the United States today
of course stamp is the enemy but my god
if you want to be an intelligent
political analyst an agent you should
also ask the obvious question where big
drum
come from what were we by this I mean
Liberal Democratic hegemony per atom
what were we doing wrong to open up the
space for Trump
I will not list your time here just I
will finish with ones conclusive said
thought to set the point to conclude
first already mentioned talking with
some of you before people say communism
has failed it has but at the same time
and that's bad news for me look what is
happening in China now I mean it is
still a communist power in this
combination communism with capitalism
are you aware what the Chinese Communist
achieved something absolutely unique
never in the history of mankind I think
did you have such a tremendous economic
development in just a couple of decades
and do you know what they did to
simplify it very much leftist rate two
things on the one hand this wild
capitalist competition market on the
other hand strong authoritarian state
which controls regulates everything
the Chinese have combined the two the
worst in an extremely successful way so
what to do here it's a very difficult
question what if our future will be and
this is not good news I don't sympathize
with them what if this type of
authoritarian capitalism is our futures
second reason of my pessimism Marxism at
least the traditional one relied on a
certain hosta Khalid pre-established
harmony that we when we are just before
the Revolution or in modern times are
facing a unique are in a unique
situation where the highest theoretical
inside communism breaking out of
capitalist blah blah can somehow be
rooted in the concrete living experience
of the majority of the people we are
palet Aryans we need
radical trend and so on and so on I
think that with problems that we are
facing today
ecology biogenetics and so on I'm more
of a pessimist I doubt if problems with
which we are really confronting today
can be in this way applied or connect
the truth mobilizing the people for
example and I will be very brutal last
sentence I promise for example here I
disagree with my otherwise good friend I
support him politically
Yanis varoufakis who says we need more
democracy in Europe and I'm always
asking me and I think at least he didn't
give me a good answer okay but are you
aware that for example with immigrant
refugees entering Europe if we were to
do a truly democratic election the
result would have been much more than a
phobic than the predominant reaction in
practically all European countries they
would have say stop stop that's what I
also learned from my diplomatic friends
when they were dealing with this problem
when the crisis was at least hype at its
high point two years ago urban for
example politicians from my country I
learned it's terrible irony they were
relatively fair saying we are
nonetheless co-responsible we have - we
are among the causes of this crisis in
the Middle East and so on in closed
sessions publicly they were much more
anti-immigrant because they knew they
would lose votes in their own country
and so on and so on
so I think we live in a very dangerous
situation where maybe the gap between
what needs to be done and simple opinion
of the many inclusive inclusive many
intellectuals I'm not saying ordinary
people are stupid intellectuals are
not they are also and just what I mean
is I'm blessed I'm just a pessimist here
miracles happen but we no longer can
have this Marxist trust in history you
know so to conclude with another one
line don't be afraid
job that I quote in my book you know
when my leftist friends remain optimists
and say don't worry the situation may be
dark but there is light at the end of
the tunnel you know what's my answer of
course it is
it's another train thanks very much for
your kind
my god I feel as if I am in a movie set
where you know they are now changing the
scene I hope you did it in a proper
cinematic Stalinist way when we will
have a Q&A with the people I hope you
did distribute the questions and the
yeah please I'm sorry I talk too much
now I'm your slave
please my first question is in the
opening chapter of the new book you talk
about philosophers becoming States
philosophers and negating the radical
potential of their philosophies to the
subservient of the existing order how do
you think philosophers can still be a
part of radical movements and what
distinguishes people like yourself who
are energized and radical politics from
those like you say like Hamas who are
just supporting the state structures oh
wait a minute maybe I was there not fair
enough now I will be very honest here
and as simple as possible
I am NOT dismissing state philosophers
wait a minute our institutions the way
we think politically and so on do do
imply a certain not philosophical in a
technical sense but a certain basic view
here I would even agree with Abram as
his great opponent Peter slaughtered Ike
right-winger but my good friend
intelligent right-winger who says that
that and although his right winger he
means is positively that the greatest
thing of our Western European insofar as
they still exist less and less welfare
state is that we don't just get what he
calls
subjective social democracy socialism we
have something that he very nicely calls
objective social democracy that is to
say social democratic values human
rights social justice and so on
inscribed into political institutions
themselves or even more silently
accepted as shared by all you know which
was the great
example of this I remember you are too
young I think it was mid seventies or a
little bit later when Social Democrats
for the first time lost power in Sweden
but then that coalition of what we when
I was young called bourgeois parties
liberals conservatives nothing changed
they nationalized even more fur it went
on because this basic social pact not so
much written rules but unwritten rules
was there and it's here it I have a
certain respect it's almost a heroic
role for habermas to say I know I will
be despised as a conformist but ok I
will play the idiot who is this but for
me if you remember then I go on and I
say that today the situation is getting
more complex and I really think that
so-called alright especially in the
United States and some other countries
change the rules because the popular
here in the UK the book by that Irish
girl who now lives in New York I met her
there in Brooklyn even angela Nagler or
what he wrote a book you should have it
at kill all the normies his idea is that
what half a century ago was a typical
left subversive attitude you know the
institutional power is severe strict
speaks with decent terms
we should provoke tell dirty jokes use
f-word
all this subversive marginal cultural
tradition but is that what happens now
is it's not symmetrical inversion but
almost an inversion all right now
behaves as formally as the new
counterculture and the horror is that
the left whatever remains of it took
refugee in political correctness in
helpless moralism and so on and so on
I don't think so
this complicated thing and that's why I
am a Leninist it's a joke but not quite
you know in what sense you know it's
very interesting to read last Lenin's
writings when he was totally desperate
he saw no socialism what can we do and
you know it what learning was obsessed
in the last two years of his life with
good manners civility and so on you know
you all if you know history of politics
and so on know that famous short
Testament that learning dictated
proposing to politburo to depose Stalin
but did you notice what our Lenin's
arguments about Stalin it's not wrong
economic politics wrong politics it is
simply Stalin doesn't have good manners
is too rough and so on now today with
Trump and so on and many other Trump's
like that borscht anuraga in Brazil and
so on
wouldn't it be that's my secret dream
now you will say this is a joke because
I am obscene no but I try to be obscene
in a non offensive way that it would be
wonderful for me for the left to say no
we are the true force of Moral Majority
we are the true force of decency you are
the dirty subversive the right-wingers
and so on I love this strategy of
changing the cards I will give another
examples in Germany one of my friend
their friends wrote a wonderful comment
where he says we should change this
perception although I don't ideally
swear that Angela Merkel is too weak
allowed too many immigrants like an old
mother losing power and then and the
immigrant nationalists present
themselves as you know courageous we
fight for our nation the point of my
friend was shouldn't we rather say
Angela Merkel is the last in the good
sense of the term great German Patriot
and strong nationalist why because to
say two million refugees you can come it
means you have
great task in your nation that it will
be able to integrate them and so on and
so on and the point is we should rather
treat all tried anti-immigrant as weak
people who don't trust their nation and
so on and so on you know I think it's
very good to mix cart like this in
political struggle so I didn't properly
answer your question but but you see in
what direction I go is not I want to ask
about the Christian materialism and the
importance of the church do you've
written about do you think that the
theological the philosophical the
normative tools that Christianity that
you find helpful are going to survive if
the church continues to decline or do
you think that the institution of the
church and adherence the church has no
bearing on those surviving materialistic
aspects it's an open question especially
Catholic Church I don't believe in it it
can be Franciscus or not I have doubts
but you know it's okay I will very
briefly give it to you the way I read
Christianity if you take it really
seriously it's really a religion of
atheism in what sense and Hegel knew
this he says the big problem is what
died on the cross Hegel says it's not
just you read Christianity in a pagan
way if you think God is up there he sent
as a messenger and then messenger died
and cry and God says God the Father okay
my son come back to me it didn't work
next time better luck and so on
no Hagel says God dies on the cross is
the very God of beyond this idea that
there is a higher power up there you
know what so paradoxical of Christianity
for me again in all other all more or
less religions the way we are here leave
we leave a fallen life and the only way
to get back
God contact is to do good work purify
yourself whatever through mystical
exercise to good deeds and so on to
climb up again I came in Christianity
don't people notices something totally
different happens and glass curtain my
go-to Catholic theology snoo it he says
that that moment le le lama sabachthani
God why have you forsaken me
it means this how do you identify with
God let's say I feel abandoned God has
left me I'm in a godless world the
Christian answer again is not ok let me
pray hard do good things
maybe I will re-establish contact is to
say but at that very point when I feel
abandoned by God
I'm identified with with Christ on the
cross who felt the same that is to say a
struggle puts it very precisely I
overcome the division from God by
transposing it into God himself
this idea that my distance from God is
inscribed into God himself
the consequences of this are then pretty
radical for example I think it's totally
wrong reading the usual one that what
will be second coming somehow Christ
will come again now Christ is dead he is
already here in holy spirit what is holy
spirit or ghost
I don't know robbery it is a simplified
very much it is it is the community of
believers and as Christ says my God in
the gospel when he is asked by one of
his people how will we know that you are
still alive that you will come he says
whenever there is love between two of
you I am there and I take this totally
literally Second Coming means that you
discover that what you are waiting for
oh my God God left just maybe he will
come again if already here in the
community of believers you don't need
God as an old guy up there a secret
guarantee and throne and so on
intelligent theologies nudies like even
a conservative like Claudell paul
claudel the great poet he said the
ultimate mystery of christianity is not
that we are important without God but
that God is important without us
okay it gets more complex but in this
sense I mean it quite literally about
being an atheist Christian I
specifically don't mean all those
simplistic ideas that Christianity can
be realized in new communist society or
whatever all those drinks no I think
that again the secret core of
Christianity is precisely this
acceptance of being on your own as
precisely divine gift you know what is
the Christian answer when you feel alone
abandoned by God just depending on
yourself the messy trees but this is
God's gift to you this is freedom that
God gave us it's much more complex
situation I don't want to lose time now
I just want to tell you that don't don't
you just think that this is some crazy
obscenity many geologists today are
moving in this direction let's take some
questions for the audience now we are in
democratic faith Democratic race only
very occasionally vela my last job
before I give you the word you know I'm
an old Platonist I already am repeating
the joke already used there so I'm all
for a dialogue with you but you know as
a lover of Plato you know it is my
favorite I look did you read late
Plato's dialogues you know how they are
written one guy talks all the time and
the other guy says every 10 minutes by
Hughes so it is Socrates and so on so
let's get this dialogue now please wait
for the microphone to come to you let's
get to the hand on the end of the oil
there in the dark blue cave yeah
actually that may ask you to do this
this is a moment of anxiety this is one
three things I can do said yeah yeah
yeah but how did you know this
politically correct and then somebody
will say what did you ignore that woman
and throw on ok sorry please professor
Dziedzic
fan of yours from South Africa yeah I
wanted to ask you in Oxford now and
sorry ask me ask you yes we're in Oxford
now and the analytical school of
philosophy is big yeah and it seems as
though that the burden always falls on
to continental philosophers to justify
their existence and I wanted you to talk
to this point the value the the the
value of continental philosophy in 21st
century thank you my position is here
much more integrated complex first I
must tell you I said there is much
boring stuff going on in so called
analytic philosophy but there are many
things which I fully admire going on
there and also for example I don't know
he now disappeared I don't know why
philosophers like saul kripke some
others and so on they did one or even
cognitivists there are very intelligent
cognitivists who raised the right
questions and so on but nonetheless and
also there is a lot of not
taking scientific breath truth
seriously going in so-called continental
philosophy the big problem for me today
is what I call the gap between realism
and transcendental approach on the one
hand we have scientific or realist
philosophical approach don't be afraid I
will try to which simply pretends to
describe reality the way it is to put it
in very simplistic terms you forget
about who you are from where you are
speaking
then we have transcendental reasoning
which is not something mystical and so
on but it's based on the simple fact
that our argumentation is ultimately
always circular for example their
reproach for example to mention the guy
that you brought habermas his basic
contribution is to claim that from the
scientific perspective one thing you
cannot explain is the normative
discursive structures of this scientific
procedure itself if you you can be very
good at scientific explanations
evolutionary and so on of this stuff
what goes on how the human intelligence
arise but in all this all this is
possible because you approached nature
in a certain way as a as a complex
cobweb of causes effects and so on and
so on this doesn't go by itself so the
idea is that we all approach reality
from a certain perspective and we cannot
ever break out of this circle and now so
that ultimately but on the other hand
it's clear that somehow although we are
always caught in our symbolic universe
and so on and if some of you follow
modern thought the ultimate in my sense
of the term now not in the strict
Kantian transcendental philosopher would
have been for example somebody like
Michel Foucault for him the ultimate
horizon of our knowledge is what he
calls a pitched me the idea that in
every epoch a certain it may be
conflictual but opposite sides always
share some presuppositions the a certain
base for example the opposition between
empiricism and irrationally
but they share a whole set of
propositions about reality and so on so
the idea is this one that this is the
ultimate thing so for example if you
were to ask Michelle Foucault do we have
an immortal soul or not his answer would
have been all I can do is to describe
the epistle the set of implicit
presuppositions within with this
question has meaning at all and if you
asked him do you believe in evolutionary
account of humanity his answer would
have been I can only tell you that this
evolutionary account is part of a modern
scientific paradigm and a--such totally
different from for example medieval
paradigm no within which meaning was
something imminent to reality itself the
universe is meaningful so what I'm
saying is that on the other hand of
course we all admit at least almost all
of us that although this is the earth
another point if there are some Marxists
here Marxists at least so-called Western
Marxists are also fully transcendental
in what sense for radical Marxist the
ultimate horizon is social practice and
as look at in the ultimate Western
Marxist work his first big book history
and class consciousness he even says
this is a classic statement nature is
historical social category which means
of course somehow we did humanity we did
emerge out of nature but what we
understand by nature is something which
is always historically over determined
and as part of our social practice
nature means something totally different
in modernity then in early then in early
Renaissance and so on
I want so we have this ultimate Tanjung
on the one hand naive scientific realism
on the other hand this transcendental
approach and what I'm obsessed with in
my last works I'm always writing the
same book and so on is precisely is it
possible to break out of this circle is
it possible to move beyond this
transcendental approach that we can just
describe the historical horizon of
meaning into which we were thrown
without returning to naive realism here
we should be creative for example who
was that guy I forgot his name often
here and that's for me the strength of
continental approach some criticism even
theological of science which can appear
stupid and it is stupid at the level of
direct scientific value can be extremely
interesting if we read it in a slightly
different way as theory of ideology for
example do you know that I forgot the
guy's name Darwin had a friend who was
who knew his work Darwin's and was at
the same time theology yes the one who
did his reply to Darwin was I forgot the
name it's a Latin name I'm too stupid
for navel you know it's the old problem
Adam is depicted with a navel but wait a
minute Adam was not born he was created
by them
does he have it so the idea is this one
and its second in green es solution he
said there been conclusively proved
through fossils and the one that our
earth or our universe was created at
least million years ago if you take
Bible literally it was 4,000 and some
years so where is the truth you know
what is the answer
of course Bible is true my god it cannot
be not true so how do we explain fossils
and so on the idea is this the same way
when you paint a state you paint the
background to create a false impression
of depth that God directly created
fossils and so on to give us a false
opening of the past and this is the best
definition of ideology I can imagine and
so on aren't we all the time inventing
traditions in this sense and so on and
so on so again to answer you properly it
may be too complex now but I try to
first I have tremendous you know what
one of my interests here maybe this
Versa returns to the latest result in
the far as I understand them I'm the
first to admit my limitation now what is
happening now in quantum physics I was
told and I read some popular books but I
try to track it with my friends who are
quantum physicists like am I totally
bluffing or does it have something that
with this quantum gravity theory and so
on there is a tremendous progress beyond
string theory going on now and I think
that some of the things that you find in
quantum physics are I think of
incredible significance to resolve this
problem because the basic presupposition
of quantum physics it's precisely that
what we perceive as natural reality is
not the ultimate reality that there is
whatever we call it quantum oscillations
and so on another level and I think that
this is cow and let's call it ontology
at the level of today's world should
function if I may go on for two three
minutes you will like it I promise I'm
sorry
and I hope you don't know this joke but
I love it a philosopher I'm very sorry I
forgot his name
you notice my senility that I forget
youth a wonderful example to explain
quantum physics and my point is the
basic paradox of quantum physics my
point is to apply it to reality as such
his idea is this one wonderful simple
metaphor a parallel between quantum
universe with lists as you know
Heisenberg uncertainty principle
although Bohr puts it in a slightly
different way but the point is this one
you know what everybody knows you cannot
measure simultaneously the the position
and the velocity movement of a particle
ok now you can read this in a decimal
logical way we just cannot measure it
Niels Bohr went a step further and
claimed it is in itself that it's not
determined in this is a wonderful vision
of reality which is in itself
ontologically incomplete and now comes
the parallel with video games aren't
they in the same similar very
superficial and a lottery incomplete in
what sense
you remember I don't play them but I
watch my son doing it and I envy him and
so on when you play a video game let's
say you see a house there but if it's
not part of the game to enter that house
then the interior of the house is not
programmed you know this you know in the
video universe it's or in the background
that is the forest but it's meaningless
to say let's go there and look in detail
at the trees no because it's not part of
the game that you can go there so in
this book the idea is this one it's very
cynical one but I love it God did
something similar he underestimated us
humans a little bit he thought that we
will never be intelligent enough to move
beyond atoms to micro particles so he
said suck it why should I lose time
programming their everything so we at
least their first dot with this pencil
you know but my point is we can how
would it be to think reality as
unfinished without this subjectivity god
whatever come is it possible to think
reality as unfinished and here I think
utopian as it may appear only a kind of
a collaboration between the best of
continental tradition no those arrogant
Europeans who despise analytic
philosophy just and the best of
analytical philosophers can do the drop
sorry I'm too long can I wait let's take
another question yeah let's go to the
hand over here alright you're a
political I know you move to the left
no I was afraid the centrist yeah behind
in the red shirt yeah there we are
prophecies they come another fan of
yours and here
yeah yeah my Nazi instict are you
Spanish no I'm Indian and from India
I'm so sorry I'm not I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry I just I I'm your pick you know
it's not racism yeah yeah so I am
studying here a course on environmental
change and management and we get to hear
this one word like Anthropocene every
now and then oak species are going
extinct when the caps are melting you
know forests tropical forests
deforestation yeah and we Club this one
thing Anthropocene always and always
like a plus what do you think about this
word I find it very uncomfortable at
times I find it funny I find it very
serious what is this word Anthropocene
the word entre pashya body what is your
take on this - Club on this young Maria
well I'm not qualified enough to Drudge
it scientifically but I like the paradox
is that this word implied namely there
is one insight in it which is correct
that all this
modern progress ISM humanity should
develop further add further that
unfortunately you find it as an
unquestioned unquestionable base even in
Marx presupposes that we can count on
nature as that vast background weak as
they say however we will screw it up
destroy ourselves and so on the Sun will
rise there will be another season and so
on that nature is inexhaustible
background I think that what we are
gradually discovering and that's for me
the first step of correct a colored
three it's not that we should go a step
further and not only admit our
responsibility with humans screwed it up
in this nice irony that precisely when
we become incredibly powerful we have we
are confronted by our limit we may
destroy the very material conditions of
our life but what I like is this what if
we change perspective and ask ourselves
if this entire perspective of human
hubris you know nature is some kind of a
balance circle but we men were too
aggressive exploitative and then you
have the idea is let's return to our
proper place and so on and so on I think
that the true horror in danger is that
if I may put it in these terms we cannot
rely on Mother Nature is this good
caring entity and we shouldn't provoke
her too much by making violent interval
what if nature is in itself a pretty
cruel not a good mother and I
always evoke these simple examples
you know whenever we talk about human
catastrophes and so on caused by
humanity don't forget that for example
our own sources of energy oil coal can
we even imagine what
kind of mega catastrophes must have
happened in prehistory of the earth
prehistory with regard to human history
that we have all these reserves so my
position is here even more tragic I am
all for ecology but without illusions I
think that we there is no natural
balance to which we can simply return
it's open it's full of risks and so on
and so on
the situation is much more over on the
second hand what interests me is this
thing we talk about
Anthropocene danger humanity blah blah
blah and here psychoanalysis maybe
enters why don't we do more something I
think that the best term some of my
friends even now published a book where
they develop this notion that it's what
psycho analysts call the mechanism of
disavowal it's not simply negation you
admit it but in an isolated forum you
reflect to draw the consequences of it
like the French term for this disavowal
phalloidin kiss the german term is just
a bien Mecca mem I know very well that
it's like this but nonetheless I don't
really believe in it so I ignore it I
think there is something of this
mechanism at work like we all know yes
global warming this there but then you
know you go out ok now not in Oxford but
in general sun is shining and so on and
you simply cannot accept it we'll all
these really beat be threatened now the
problem is then how to awaken us truly I
want to avoid the conclusion that many
of my leftist friends are attracted to
that we need one big mega catastrophe
that only this will awaken humanity you
know while I am afraid of this because
again it's this typical traditional
Marxist mr.
how do they know that the result of this
catastrophe will be some Society of
solidarity socialism what if it will be
a much more authoritarian society and so
on but my point where maybe I if I got
your the if I got the trust of your
question correctly where I share your
interest is that although ecology is the
topic today we should all the more
carefully analyze all the ideological
threats that are there and in this way I
will now very briefly Libya return to
your question I forgot what can
philosophers do I don't believe
philosophers can answer they can raise
the right question they can this is
philosophy at its best when with ecology
with racism and so on it shows how the
very way we formulate a problem is part
of the problem reproduces the problem
and so on and so on my classical example
is fierce harassment harassment okay
real harassment sexual harassment
nothing against but the term harassment
even tolerance are of limited use even
in fighting racism because I always make
this experiment which right right go to
the web and download Martin Luther
King's speeches and look for tolerance
in them practically non-existing terms
when you confront racism as a problem of
Tolerance it's already a certain
reduction to cultural tolerance we
should tolerate each other and so on
with harassment it's the same harassment
has always dissed as it were
narcissistic undertone in the sense of
you know keep at a distance don't come
too close to me I think that harassment
the fear of harassment is not simply the
fear of beth harassment it is always
also
the fear of simply the over proximity of
the real actual other and you find this
against even with leftist who like
immigrant but then if you look closely
at their emitter of immigrants you see
that it's that's my dirty word it's like
you know in today's society I always use
this example we like to get a product
but in its cleansed form like like beer
yes but without alcohol chocolate yes
but without fat coffee yes but without
coffee
and I claim that what we call sex is
precisely sex with the hot sex and and
what we claim as standard bourgeois
multiculturalism is precisely
culturalism without the real other you
know there is nothing more racist for me
than this for example American liberal
image of so-called Native Americans who
their holistic they don't just exploit
nature they're in a dialogue with nature
and so on and so on
I cannot imagine more implicitly racist
thing than this false respect of the
other I know again I didn't answer your
question but it that's life thank
you
one more we take yeah just one more
final question let's go this one can be
a room my god I feel learning woman you
want to ask a question yes there's a
woman at the back I think I don't see
anything very patronizing but I want to
save my or as I like to say ironically
precisely because privately I'm not a
good feminist I have to cover it up by
okay so in your talk you define populism
not as an active perhaps cult of
personality surrounding a leader or even
a leader being promoted through things
like means an internet culture but as an
active enemy creation would you say that
even for example the British like left
at the moment because you said this was
a problem both on the left and the right
that's specifically in Britain that
perhaps like Jeremy Corbyn and the
Labour Party at the moment have created
an enemy and if so what would you say it
is no I'm greatly sympathetic to Corbin
although I'm not an economist and I
don't know what would have happened but
it's not that they are economically
stupid you know our economic reality is
not an objective fact the way markets
react
it's full of prejudices fears and so on
and so on and what I fear is all my
friends is that lets say Corbin Labour
Party comes to power and then there is
some kind of a panicky market reaction
and so on and you can say it's
irrational but the effects can be very
real but another point I wonder if you
would agree I follow a little bit the
debate and precisely what I maybe I'm
wrong
relatively like about Corbin is that
whatever he is
people usually even reproach him for
that but I like that he is not a
demagogic charismatic populist if there
is almost a bland person effort it not
it's him and I thought I think he cannot
compare with real European
police although they are not all bad but
look at podemos is for me what I have in
mind as long as they played this game of
and when I said in my introductory five
minutes which lasted 25 minutes when I
said that how how we cannot count on
this in advance harmony this is why the
populist formula at least of Iglesias in
Spain was forget he even used virgle
words all the screw ideologies
socialism communism turn to ordinary
people listen to their actual demand
troubles and so on and so on
unfortunately I don't believe in this of
course up to a point we should do it but
look where it brought podemos they got
their 15 percent or whatever and you
know I'm always fascinated by it's easy
to be a protest party you register
protest of the people and so on but then
look at their electoral program in the
last elections it wasn't even a very
radical social democracy and people were
disappointed because all the big
rhetorics
listening to real people and so on ended
up in very very modest proposes raise
the taxes a little bit here and so on
up and down you see that's another
problem that I have with a very notion
of populism is that it is for me this
will be a general reflection too much it
relies too much to an idea of emergency
state populist moment is it's not normal
it's antagonism Tanjung and so on but I
think and here radical leftist but very
earth careful one I think that the
really crucial moment of every
revolution is when things sooner or
later stabilized when life returns to
normal
how do ordinary people feel the differ
at that point I hate this big thing clue
1 million people on the square there
yeah and what happens then like in Arab
Spring you have 1 million people on
Tahrir Square and then you get Muslim
Brotherhood and now you get military
regiment so on and so on in Greece it
was a tragedy I blame them but you got
the biggest popular mobilization syriza
at the end are we aware what totally
crazy things happened there syriza which
built its reputation on rejecting
austerity became the most faithful
executor of austerity so you see that
much sketches of populism I I don't
think it addresses or answers the true
question that I'm very naive
old-fashioned also I don't believe in
traditional Marxist answers Marxist here
the big problem is and all other things
are do we have a serious
feasible alternative to global
capitalism or are we all enlightened
leftist Fukuyama lists which means
Fujiyama was basically right democracy
capitalism with rush let's move it a
little bit towards the left and so on
and so on and I don't see any communist
party or whatever saving us I'm a
pessimistic communist in the sense that
I think that with regard to problems
that we are facing today
ecology immigrants or this not just
immigrants this global world disorder
mega topic
biogenetics all the experiments today
prospects of directly wiring or brain
linking that who will control this what
will be the result of all this I don't
think that the way our societies are
structured now economically and
politically is appropriate to even
properly confront these questions and
I'm here
pessimists because I'm the first to
admit that what we knew till now as
communism was if anything even worse in
it I just am again a communists out of
despair I see the need for a radical
trend but there is no predetermination
maybe it will not happen maybe Hollywood
is right by Hollywood is right I mean
it's incredible how even Hollywood sees
this dark prospect in all this in all
this post catastrophic movies hunger
game and so on and so on in some sense
they are right we are approaching a new
divided society I mean are we aware what
trump means every functioning democracy
has to rely on a set of shared
presuppositions you can have all the
Poli mix and so on but against the
background on not just procedural but
even more substantial presuppositions
about the basics of economic order about
the basis of democratic decision and
turbulent ones and that's what is
happening now in the United States
it's literally already an ideological
civil war this shared ground which was
still now very operative between
Republicans and Democrats is
disintegrating and my belief is that
what Trump did I will not say his great
result but he did something he ruined
this liberal democratic consensus shared
by all and maybe we should be courageous
enough to admit that the solution is not
simply to re-establish that consensus
but that we should propose another
consensus a little bit more to the left
what fluttered I called objective social
democracy because I think again that
it's a tremendous
strain that today it's not only Trump
Trump is part of the global movement
what happens in China and so on where a
new authoritarian capitalism is emerging
and again it's a very dangerous
situation that's right to conclude I
don't agree with those who cry fascism
fascism this is the worst manner of old
leftists they are too lazy to think
which is when something emerges which
nobody likes instead of thinking it
seriously
they just reduce it to some old things
which already happened and we don't like
Trump fascism
no sorry Trump is not simply a fascist
my god even this alt-right populism now
is not simply it is not simply fascism I
think we really live in a dangerous
situation but again my hope is I often
although I'm well aware of the horrors
of Maoism Great Leap Forward up to 50
million dead and so on but I still
admire that saying by Mao there is
disorder under the heaven so the
situation is excellent we we shouldn't
be afraid to act in this situation I
stop thank you very much thank you very
much
you